man's life has changed significantly
when we learned to use optical devices
for research 410 years has passed since
the time when Galileo Galilei pointed a
3 power spyglass at the moon and just 29
years since the launch of Hubble the
first space observatory today the
distance to the edge of the observable
universe equals approximately 14 billion
parsecs and this may well be called just
the beginning of our exploration it is
interplanetary space probes that are
going to herald the next stage the most
famous ones like the voyages on you
horizons unknown world wide but among
spacecraft like these there are veterans
as well one of them is the Cassini
interplanetary orbiter which started its
mission back in 1997 and completed it
quite recently what did the spacecraft
discover and what did it get to observe
in the 20 years of its historic mission
originally the Cassini project implied
exploring Saturn added satellites and
delivering the Huygens Lander to Titan
the project was made real by the efforts
of several organizations including NASA
ESA the Italian space agency and others
about 260 scientists from 17 countries
were involved with the project the
Huygens Lander was created by the
European Space Agency with a systems
section produced by Lockheed Martin
specialists one of NASA's departments
was in charge of the flight the initial
weight of the spacecraft was 5 tons 719
kilos its height was six point seven
meters and its width four meters the 320
kilo probe 336 kilo scientific
instruments and 3310 kilos of fuel all
added to the impressive way to the
spacecraft Cassini was powered by
radioisotope thermoelectric generators
using radioactive plutonium-238 for fuel
also the spacecraft had 12 scientific
instruments onboard among them a mass
spectrometer an ultraviolet radar a
magnetometer and others the spacecraft
was launched on October the 15th 1997
from Cape Canaveral in order to gain the
desired speed the spacecraft was
initially flown in the opposite
direction from Saturn and past Venus
twice then in August 1999 Cassini flew
by the earth of the speed of 69 thousand
kilometers per hour it used the
opportunity to test its cameras and take
a splendid picture of our satellite
after this the biggest planet of the
solar system was awaiting it Jupiter
which was passed by the spacecraft on
December 30 2000 Cassini managed to take
quite a number of pictures of this
planet as well as a few of its
satellites thus providing substantial
amount of scientific data including
Jupiter's atmospheric circulation as
soon as on the 30th of June 2004 the
spacecraft reached Saturn and achieved
its final goal by becoming the planet's
first artificial satellite it was
coasting at the orbital speed of 15
kilometers per second the Huygens probe
onboard the Cassini spacecraft was
supposed to take it from there on the
25th of December 2004 Huygens detached
itself to set out of his deliberate way
to the surface of Titan even before gas
Eenie entered into orbit around Saturn
on the 14th of January 2005 the probe
penetrated the atmosphere of the
mysterious satellite it touched down in
a hard surface two and a half hours
later in the following 72 minutes
Cassini received signals from the probe
on the Titan surface and beamed back 350
images to the earth thanks to the data
received it became known that there were
not only rivers and lakes on Titan but
rounded hydrocarbon pebbles and methane
clouds Cassini undertook further
exploration of the satellite in the
period of 13 years it flew by Saturn's
largest satellite over a hundred times
and stumbled upon a great number of
discoveries the most fascinating of the
was that Islands on Titan's lakes
submerged and reemerged however the
precise mechanism of this phenomenon
remains to be found out during the time
Cassini was operating astronomers from
the earth discovered seven new Saturn's
satellites thanks to the pictures
transmitted from a spacecraft with the
very first discoveries made during the
time Cassini was approaching
in Saturn's new moons were dubbed
Bellini Polydeuces and muthoni while
Cassini remained in Saturn's orbit there
were discovered satellites later named
Daphne's anthe Aegean and a curious
satellite s 2009 s1 which hasn't been
given a name yet this satellite is the
closest to its planet speaking about the
most impressive discoveries made by
Cassini do fascinating phenomena may be
singled out these are all Rory and
Saturn's atmosphere and an exciting
hexagonal jet stream with a red
hurricane inside
soon after Cassini's discovery of this
mysterious hexagon another unaccountable
property of the vortex was registered by
astronomers with passing years the
vortex changed its color the area of
this hurricane is 50 times that of the
average hurricane on the earth the next
objective for exploration was Saturn's
rings it should be noted that some of
them like the anthe arc or the pelini
ring were discovered by Cassini itself a
number of finer details were revealed by
Cassini as it observed the Rings for
example how Sheppard's satellites like
Daphne's kept close watch on the Rings
and how a nice belt
built up on them it was also thanks to
the Cassini mission that had became
known that there is a water ocean under
the crust of Enceladus just like under
the crust of some of Jupiter's
satellites
this ocean might have the correct
chemistry for sustaining life
but unlike Europa or Ganymede the ocean
on Enceladus is possible for us to
explore Cassini flew through its Keyes's
a number of times the data received are
soon going to be used for creating
devices for a new mission to Saturn
Europa clipper
in the 13 years Cassini spent on
Saturn's orbit it received 635 gigabytes
of data and took almost half a million
photos before the spacecraft was
launched only 18 of Saturn's satellites
were known to scientists in the seven
years Cassini was traveling to Saturn 13
more satellites were spotted and during
the spacecraft's operation 22 more
satellites were discovered seven of
which directly thanks to Cassini's
pictures today we know 82 satellites of
this planet 20 of them were discovered
quite recently
this makes Saturn the richest planet and
satellites in the solar system at the
end of its mission Cassini discovered
yet another surprising phenomenon a
space between Saturn's rings just before
the missions grand finale the spacecraft
positioned itself between rings and
instead of expected dust vortices it
observed just an absolutely empty space
Cassini's fate was sealed in may 2017
due to the lack of fuel any further
operation of a spacecraft in orbit who
is no longer possible
the missions management considered 19
options of the probes destiny one of
them involved steering to orbit around
the Sun or one of Saturn's satellites
but in the end it was decided to let
Cassini burn up in the gas giants
atmosphere the decision was supposed to
prevent the Saturn satellites possible
biological contamination
on the 22nd of April 2017 Cassini
performed a maneuver around Titan and
found itself between Saturn and its
closest trained the spacecraft kept
taking pictures till the very end this
is what its last photo beamed back to
the earth looked like
[Music]
on entering the planet's atmosphere the
spacecraft pointed its aerial to the
earth and began transmitting data about
the chemistry of Saturnian atmosphere
soon after the connection with the
orbiter was lost it burned up in the
dense strata of Saturnian atmosphere
even though the Cassini mission wasn't
as tremendous as missions to Mars it
proved extremely useful to contemporary
astronomy the spacecraft brought
scientists up to speed with truly unique
images on a monthly basis thanks to
these many aspiring astronomers built
their careers using this database the
result of the mission indeed surpassed
all expectations because today we can
realistically talk about discovering
life on Saturnian satellites perhaps we
will soon find out about these
discoveries and then it will be
perfectly clear who to give credit for
this
I do hope you enjoyed the video please
don't hesitate to hit the like button
and subscribe if you are so inclined and
look out for our new videos bye bye
[Music]